oh my god and his head goes through the
walls
what is happening i got to check out the
worst rated medical games i did it last
year and i want to see if anyone's
learned any lessons
you with me we found our first victim
kids
doctor clinic one review two stars
free weird icon i'm clicking on it let
play
baby kids doctor clinic game kid doctor
clinic
is a game that make you a doctor we
promise to create good app for kids
every week
thank you so much i think the problem
here is is they're creating a new app
every week
perhaps take a month let it you know
test it a little bit
it's definitely gonna hack into my phone
and steal my credit card information or
something but let's see i love that on
the bottom there's
ads for uh malpractice suits
philadelphia
injury attorney what child is clicking
on this all right there's a child here
i have a thermometer i have what looks
like a tongue depressor a stethoscope
and a flashlight i don't know why
there's a flashlight in case there's a
blackout
thermometer says thermometer didn't say
anything
what is going on you click the
flashlight and you look inside its mouth
and there's like a little
devil in there what is it there's an
octopus inside this child's mouth
how you could wipe the baby's tears and
it makes a really awkward sound when you
do
there's no learning there's no doing
there's literally just like you're
clicking buttons
and there's so many malpractice ads in
this game it's kind of frightening to me
are adults playing this why
bear come play this game with me buddy
it's called little bear hospital dr game
for kids come up here
hey little bear doctor our animal
friends are sick now
please help to treat them with advanced
medical facilities and
comfortable environment no you don't
care bear it's not recognizing my face
because you're licking me oh now i have
to enter my password
it won't even load
it's seriously not loading it's good
music though
seems like russian music
[Music]
no i don't want notifications from the
crazy hospital all right we have charlie
age
28 years old oh charlie's a little
creepy
looks like charlie has had a terrible
reaction to something he ate
his face has loads of spots as a result
use a spot cream to clear up those spots
and perform a general checkup
well medically this is a little
inaccurate if a patient came in and was
having allergic reaction as to something
they ate
facial swelling could be an early form
of anaphylaxis you may need to
administer an epipen also do you want to
put
topical steroids on the face if it's
short
term and under careful eye of a doctor
maybe i don't know
let's see let's see how i can treat this
gentleman's face
okay there buddy see these don't look
like hives
these look like infected pustules i
would treat these with antibiotics
but oh
oh sir cover your mouth it's covet is
this a toothbrush i'm gonna brush his
teeth
oh those are some bad teeth sir you have
plaque
we need to get it out you wanna brush
your teeth like you're brushing a tomato
not too hard dentist told me that oh
cool he has fungus
on his nails but i'm just clipping them
giving him a manicure oh do you know
what i'm doing here
he has infected hair follicles so i'm
pulling those hairs feels like a beauty
treatment more than a hospital visit
though not gonna lie
use the ice cold and swell to heal this
nasty bruise
oh man i wish cold just heals bruises
this quickly unfortunately it takes some
days to clear up a bruise
a bruise is essentially broken blood
vessels underneath the skin and you
can't just make that disappear overnight
all right now i get why this game has
three and a half stars it's not terrible
although i just don't understand why
it's making me do certain things like he
came
with a rash on his face and here i am
cutting his fingernails
and brushing his teeth beans beans the
musical fruit the more you eat the more
you toot
i think our brave pirate jack needs a
tummy rub to get rid
that wind after eating all those beans
rub jack's stomach to help him ease the
wind that he has
this is awkward and there's a giant hand
i just had to massage a pirate's belly
as he moaned and i heard squirting
noises
to help him pass wind clearly someone's
taking advantage of the universal
healthcare system
wherever that was wait what little ed's
junior gym doctor
jim is the perfect place to get the
proper fitness tips to keep our body
more beautiful
and more shining in this little edge
junior gym doctor game you can perform
tons of gymming exercises
like boxing weightlifting dumbbells
starching
balls i'm gonna play this game for one
reason
i need to know what starching balls is
oh i'm gonna put him on the stationary
bike oh you could actually like make him
do it
[Music]
he's in the doctor's office now these
are band-aids
but what's wrong with his leg sorry
little ed
i'm not a fan i like your pink bike
though accident reported
go to the place provide them first aid
oh my god is this like one of those oh
it's not a bad driving simulator
actually i mean you just go straight
oh patient looks in pain give him first
aid asap
why is the paramedic or emt in scrubs
and a face mask maybe because it's
covered why is a patient on the floor
you need a back brace you need to do
abc's
come on man this is a trauma take the
patient to the hospital
no problem again hospitals straight
ahead
clearly they did didn't did not design a
map here
[Music]
i've crashed this ambulance two times
time to walk this
patient in oh my god
this looks like he's just floating
oh my god and his head goes through the
walls what is happening
oh there's footsteps
but where's my patient's head he looks
decapitated whoa
why is there a sniper oh that's another
game press button to start surgery
oh start surgery antiseptic ball
okay good job apply cotton on finger
great work now apply sanitizer strips on
wound
i don't know what those sanitizer wipes
were but and that cuts not really on his
finger
so instead of putting the cut on his
finger they just put it on the bed all
right this game gets a
for accuracy but not bad for um in terms
of
game development like if i was going to
develop my own game maybe i'll hit him
up
swine flu prevention pig game it's made
by a person named pig
shooter hello friends
space exclamation point we are here to
introduce you a swine flu prevention pig
game
swine flu prevention pig game
exclamation point is a game that helps
you handle disease
like swine flu in a funny way dot dot
dot
those are owls you're using the wrong
animal noise
do i have iga nephropathy
what is with these medical ads there's a
little heart at the top of the screen
that says video ads
who just wants to see video ads who
would just be like
you know what i'm cool playing skit but
let me see those video ads real quick
cut the infected pig oh this is like
fruit ninja
oh my god this is weird i'm playing
fruit ninja with pigs oh that wasn't an
infected pig i caught the wrong pig
real doctor hates this game wow it's
like freezing my phone
oh my god sick baby care a little doctor
little doctor sick baby care is a new
addition to baby care doctor salon game
if you love baby doctor care new baby
and dr
kid salon games then you are surely
going to enjoy this game
treat this little girl in the game she's
just a dirty food
which is not good for health and got
sick it's time to treat her and give her
first dates and she is crying
take her to the doctor clinic check her
temperature pulse and blood pressure
once done give her appropriate medicine
make her smile again by treating her the
right way
okay there's a young woman slash
child sitting in front of what looks
like to be a big mac and fries and a
beer
she should be drinking a beer
i have to feed it to her
mom i am feeling sick well obviously the
doctor just fed you a burger
check the temperature and heartbeat
give her injection
the grammar in these games
great sound effects too give her
medicine
i always wonder what kind of injections
are they giving to these children
it's giving her three pills that's a lot
of
they pills shoot into her mouth from the
thing give her syrup and wipe her tears
oh look i'm wiping her tears this is the
worst wiping of the tears i've ever seen
only in a game do you have to do this to
someone's face to wipe their tears like
for me you go like this
tears wipe for this baby yippee
thanks doctor i am fine now that's the
entire game
who made you
and why
wow oh my god i have the full name of
the game now that i'm ready to delete it
delete sick baby care a little dr first
aid salon and baby hospital care game
where was there a little baby in the
first place i was treating a teenager
please give me suggestions for more
games to play
i heard that surgeon simulator may be
having something new come out soon on
the grapevine and i'm excited about that
but if you have any bad games for me to
play that you've come across definitely
let me know in the comments as well
and don't forget to check out my patreon
that's listed down below
i have two hilarious videos for you to
watch here
memes and the onion which one you're
watching as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]